alicia good afternoon how can i help you
hey um well
i'm in a bit of a conundrum and i kind
of feel like i'm about to have a bigger
break though so that's kind of why i
told you guys
all right um so basically
i started schooling for cosmetology
about a year ago
um i was not allowed to go to school
straight out of
high school i was home
took a while to get kind of out of that
so basically didn't start going to
school
until i was um 30 and
however during that time well really
before that i was
doing contracting work for a startup
company
um had some experience already in that
industry
and so i was i was working as a
contractor for them
um and basically that company has grown
to be
a 10 million dollar company and as it's
grown i've used
company
um my husband makes about 70.
um so basically it's going right now
i it has become not something that like
i
i enjoy in sort of something that i'm
doing because
i don't want to quit because my dad
always quit
but i'm just so spread in right now and
i just
feel like i should quit but then the
streets in the back of my head says
but what if this business fails or
what if you get there which i've been
told you're like a founding member of
the company you're not gonna get tired
hey alicia hello
alicia you're not your dad
okay hello yeah you hear me alicia
yes you are not your dad
i want you to say that say no say the
words out loud
say i am not my dad not my dad i am
alicia
say i am alicia
that's right no no no say that again
because you're talking about yourself
i'm going to say that one more time say
it firm
as a matter of fact scream that joker if
you need to
i'm alicia there you go and i'm not my
dad
i'm not my dad yeah so listen to me
super carefully all right alicia
you have been through hell
and it would be a disservice to call it
anything less than that
and every moment of every day you were
living out of that childhood trauma
you're living out of the nonsense people
put you through
and none of that defines you you are not
your yesterday
and you are in a remarkable relationship
you have found some expertise and some
strength
and a professional role that doesn't
define you either by the way
but you are living into something you're
being successful at it
and you're going to school and you've
smart enough
god almighty listen alicia you are smart
enough and you know your heart well
enough to know i'm spread too thin right
now i need to let something go so
yes all the blessings you don't need my
blessing by the way you're a smart and
brilliant woman
and i guarantee you you know the answer
i'm about to tell you take a break
take a break kick butt on your job
tell those suckers to pay you more than
40 000 by the way and
be the best partner you can to your
husband
and when school circles back around my
mom went to school
at 42 for the first time and she is a 70
year
old gangster right now with a phd
running a department
i got a second graduate degree halfway
through my life
dude you got all the time in the world
alicia what
what once you take this break what are
you going to be doing
what will you be doing with your time
um honestly like with my job i really
don't have a lot of time which is why i
am spread so bad and one of the reasons
why i'm being
paid what i am is just because um my
boss is basically letting me off work
early on the days i have to go to school
so he just he didn't want to invest in
someone who's going to eventually leave
because
the industry that i'm in has nothing to
do with cosmetology
well and hey you've got a built-in
you've got a built-in gap right now
if anyone asks you in the future you can
say
they'll say hey why'd you quit school
why'd you take uh a two years off and
you can say remember 2020
and they'll go oh yeah that's cool right
you got it so here's the thing alicia um
[Music]
i'mma rock with john on this one my only
thing for you is to still be productive
and to still be doing something wise
with your time
while you take a break i don't want you
to take a break just to be taking a
break take a break so you can that way
you can come back with something
stronger and better
you've been through a lot maybe take a
few months off
but still be productive still figure out
something to do with your life